okay so this presentation we're going to
kind of focus on the evolution of life
on Earth and you're gonna see that we
kind of start off with an outerspace
theme to this presentation so let's go
ahead and get started
so we'll start before we go into life on
earth let's just go over the general
general way in which not just our solar
system but we think solar systems in
general form here we have a picture of
what's called a nebula and we'll go into
nebulas in just a moment but let's focus
for a moment on some and some of some
facts about the earth and our solar
system first of all the earth is
believed to be about 4.6 BYO means
billion years old and this number has
been reached numerous times by a method
of radiometric dating which we talked
about earlier in this chapter so
radiometric dating is where they look at
isotopes and based upon the amount of
decay that an isotope has gone through
we can kind of we can mathematically
calculate a fairly accurate estimate of
its age we know that isotopes will decay
at a known rate so if something is older
the then more time has passed for the
isotope to decay and therefore it's
older if something if a rock or a fossil
is more recent than less time has passed
for the isotopes to decay and the
specimen would be younger
so through radiometric dating of rocks
not just earth rocks but mainly meteor
rocks outer space rocks that have struck
earth we've been able to estimate that
the earth and the solar system are
around 4.6 billion years old and so
let's reference this picture here this
is one of my favorite pictures of a
nebula right here nebulas they have this
poetic phrase to them this poetic name
they're called the birthplace of stars
and you know this picture looks quite
small keep in mind it's a picture from
from a very far distance this picture
was taken from the telescope from the
Hubble Space Telescope I believe and
this is a image of a nebula and this
nebula is then called the lion's mane or
the lion nebula the lion's mane nebula I
think and use your imagination looks
like there's a lion's head
in the middle of that circle so the
lion's mane nebula and so nebulas again
are called
the birthplace of stars because what we
have is a lot of gas and dust and I'm
not talking about dust like you find in
your house but but the gas and dust are
mainly like hydrogen and helium and and
these are gases that when they compress
when gravity brings these gases together
and they compress they ignite in
diffusion and that is what creates a
star so these are just a few pictures of
some various nebulae that I just kind of
thought were pretty for all you rock and
roll fans right here this I believe was
the album art of a Pearl Jam album in
the mid 90s but if I'm not mistaken this
is called the fisheye in nebula looks
like a fisheye in the middle I don't
know the name of this nebula I just
thought it was again a really pretty
picture and this is also one of my
favorite ones this is called the
Horsehead Nebula if you use your
imagination you can kind of see a horse
head in that cloud of gas and dust right
there and so again these are these are
where stars are formed so gravity will
pull this gas and dust together it will
compress in in the the gas and dust will
ignite in the into a star into a Sun and
so this leads us to what we call the
nebula hypothesis so if you follow the
pictures ABCDE we have a nebula in area
a in the nebula is being compressed by
gravity and area B it's Beacon being
more compressed in Area C being more
compressed in area D and so what we not
have is if you notice in the middle what
we have as the Sun has ignited and again
because of a lot of this gas and dust
that was in the nebula is compressed due
to gravity and then fusion begins all
that pressure causes fusion which is the
ignition of a star and so what we see is
that a lot of this a lot of as gravity
is pulling all this
gas and dust of the middle a lot of
solid chunks form closest to the star
and on the edge of the star the smaller
gas particles and this kind of explains
our solar system so we'll go over the
solar system in just a moment again but
here we have just kind of an artist
drawing here of a of a nebula and of you
can see a star in the middle and this
gas is swirling and swirling around
because of the gravity from the star in
the middle and so this is swirling
clumps materials together to form
planets and so what doesn't get pulled
into the Sun what doesn't get pulled
into the Sun forms planets and if you
look at our picture of our solar system
here if you look at the inner planets
Mercury Venus Earth and Mars again what
we have are very rocky worlds very rocky
terrestrial worlds now whenever I see
pictures like this it kind of drives me
nuts because this is nowhere near to
scale the planets are not evenly spaced
out like you see right here there's a
huge gap when you get to Mars there's a
huge gap from Mars to Jupiter I
understand why you can't show that in
the picture because again you know you
have a little bit of space to work with
but what gravity does is it pulls the
heavier solid objects to the middle and
that's why our middle inner planets are
rocky and the lighter outside planets
are gas giants Jupiter Saturn Uranus
Neptune these are gas planets there's no
solid surface to walk it so this kind of
in general goes oh the goes over the
hypothesis for how we think solar
systems form if we kind of focus on
earth for a moment well we know that
primitive earth was very different and
at one time we believed primitive earth
primitive earth did not have a moon this
picture shows an artist's drawing of a
large planet sized object slamming into
primitive earth this collision just
completely
they destroyed primitive earth and this
this large object that ran into earth
but instead of primitive earth being
just completely obliterated gravity
again pulled most of the debris back
together with a small chunk on the
outside that started rotating around
earth and we now call this the moon one
reason why we think the moon and the
earth were once part of one another is
because we when we landed on the moon
and brought back rocks we noticed that
the composition of moon rocks is the
same as composition of rocks here on
earth
so it's a really good sign that if the
moon is made from what earth is made
from there they very well could have
been this one at a de at one time in our
history
so let's kind of focus on ancient earth
this picture might be a little hard to
read based on the quality of the video
here but it says the primitive
atmosphere contains gases including
water vapour that escaped from volcanoes
as the water vapor cooled some gases
were washed into the ocean by rain so
we're gonna focus on early ancient earth
in just a moment and what we know again
we get this information we can't time
travel of course but we can look at
things that were around billions of
years ago we can look at little clues
and the best piece of information is in
rocks rocks are again large lumps of
minerals and so whatever minerals are
trapped in rocks of let's say 3 billion
years old then that's a really good sign
that if there's ammonia in even 4
billion year old rock then earth had a
lot of ammonia at durin during that time
in its history if there's a lot of
methane trapped in four billion year old
rock then we know that four billion
years ago earth had a lot of methane in
the atmosphere and so by looking at the
contents of rocks were able to tell that
the atmosphere of the earth had these
various components right here ammonia
water methane and carbon dioxide these
were very abundant at one time in
Earth's history the climate of ancient
earth also very different than the
climate today you know the average
worldwide temperature at any given day
on planet Earth is something around like
57 degrees the average worldwide
temperature very mild most people would
consider 57 degrees a nice pleasant day
but what we know from studying rocks
again is that earth was very different
billions of years ago the earth was a
hotter small Vulcan more volcanically
active place and again we know this from
looking at rocks when we see a lot of
volcanic rock you know four billion
years ago well that means that there's
volcanoes were more active when we see
evidence of heat scarring on rocks then
we know that again Earth was a lot
warmer
and these are things that these are
clues that we are able to find to make a
determination that you know earth a long
time ago is very different and here you
see kind of an artist drawing of what
Earth may have looked like well one of
the things that we mentioned was in the
atmosphere was water vapor and here we
have an animation of a process known as
condensation
well eventually the climate of the earth
began to cool the volcanoes became less
active eventually the amount of meteor
strike in Earth slowed down because
again a lot of meteors were being
swallowed up by the Sun a lot of meteor
meteor struck other planets and so the
amount of meteors in the solar system
began to decrease and so the earth began
to cool off less volcanic activity less
meteor impacts and think about what is
water vapor remember water vapor is a
gas what is water vapor do when
temperatures begin to cool and that's
what this animation is showing this
animation shows a process called
condensation when water vapor cools it
condenses and that leads to rain and so
even science believes that at one time
there is a great flood that helped to
create the oceans of ancient earth a lot
of water vapor from volcanoes were was
released into the atmosphere and over
time that water vapor cooled well you
all know the expression what goes up
must come down and so this helped to
form the oceans that we see today
or to bring up an experiment that was
performed in the 1950s at the University
of Chicago my hometown Chicago but at
there's a to these two scientists right
here at believe the names are Walter
Miller and Stanley urate help it and
flip-flop their first names there but
they did an experiment at the University
of Chicago in the 1950s and I want to
kind of summarize what their experiment
was they had a hypothesis they they were
they were working under the thinking
that you know if they try to simulate
what early earth was like if they try to
recreate the conditions of early Earth
would they be able to create organic
molecules organic molecules and
molecules based on carbon that are
required by living organisms organic
molecules like proteins like lipids like
nucleic acids like carbohydrates and so
they were wondering well what is the
spark literally what what what could be
the spark that could have reshuffled
these molecules and so they started
thinking well what type of energy was
available on earth well they knew that
we knew that the earth was a lot more
volcanic we also know that
storms brings lightning and so they
thought maybe lightning could provide
the energy to help we combine atoms and
molecules
so what they did was they set up a
little gas chamber and in this gas
chamber they added various gases and
you'll start to see some of the gases
that they added here's one of them NH 2
NH 2 is a symbol for ammonia in their
gas chamber they circulated ammonia
throughout the gas chamber
they also circulated h2o known as water
so they circulated ammonia through this
gas chamber they circulated water vapor
through this gas chamber what else did
they add they circulated methane
methane's formula is ch4 so water vapor
ammonia methane
I hope this list is looking familiar
these were circulated through the gas
chamber others one more that they added
and I hope you remember what it was
co2 carbon dioxide they circulate a
carbon dioxide methane water vapor
leaper ammonia the very gases that were
thought to be present in the atmosphere
of ancient earth billions and billions
of years ago and again they needed a
spark they figured they needed an energy
source so they added a couple of
electrodes which added zaps of
electricity and in this these electrodes
simulated lightning we know lightning is
fairly common on earth today so they
figured it was fairly common on earth
back then as well and this energy this
energy in the electricity did something
to these molecules look what it did
you
the energy from the lightning broke
apart the individual atoms of ammonia
water methane and carbon dioxide it
broke apart into individual atoms of
carbon hydrogen oxygen nitrogen well we
all should know from an earlier chapter
that atoms don't like to be single like
this because these atoms are all
unstable and what do unstable atoms do
well they look to recombine these atoms
look to reshuffle share electrons form
covalent bonds and so look what happened
in there at the end results of their
experiment and a weird thing started to
happen these atoms started to recombine
with other atoms and when the atoms
started to recombine they started to
recombine into molecules called amino
acids
now amino acids you should remember from
earlier in the school year are really
important organic molecules to life
they're the building blocks of proteins
so a pop a formula a formula of an amino
acid just popped up on screen you can
see that there's nitrogen in amino acids
well that came from the ammonia you can
see that there's hydrogen in amino acids
well that could have come from either
the ammonia the water or the methane you
can see there's carbon in the amino
acids well the carbon either came from
the methane or the carbon dioxide you
can see there's oxygen in the amino
acids well the oxygen either came from
water or from carbon dioxide so when all
these when all these molecules of
ammonia water methane and carbon dioxide
were broken apart they recombined into
amino acids later on other scientists
not Miller and Urey other scientists
were able to do a similar experiment
like this and we're actually able to
recreate nucleic acids DNA so these this
experiment showed that very very
important molecules like amino acids and
nucleotides very important molecules to
life
can be created from inorganic molecules
which existed a long time ago in Earth's
history
you
and so that kind of just touches on the
importance of Miller and Eurasia big
experiment here remember that a chain of
amino acids makes up a protein and so
they were able to prove that organic
molecules such as proteins others were
able to prove that organic molecules
such as nucleotides DNA and RNA could be
formed without the presence of life it
didn't require a living organism inside
of that gas chamber to create these
molecules that are very much required
for life one thing I want to stress did
they create life no they did not create
life in a test tube that would have been
awesome if they did but no they didn't
so the reason again one of the other
reasons why we bring up Miller and URIs
experiment was again you know the
thinking that perhaps this could be an
early step in the evolution of the
evolution towards life on earth because
we know at one time Earth had absolutely
no life on it but then life began which
we think prokaryotes so how did that
transition happen and you know science
we don't have all the answers yeah that
we're trying to piece together a puzzle
that happened three and a half billion
years ago it's not an easy task to do so
we're trying to find little clues along
the way and the thought is if perhaps
this could be one of those clues so we
don't really have a good understanding
for how exactly did life evolved from
from nothing into something we don't
have that good idea and when I say
nothing I don't literally mean nothing
though because we know that there were
inorganic molecules on earth such as
ammonia water methane carbon dioxide but
we don't really have a good
understanding of how did organic life
begin on on earth but again this
experiment brings up possibly a step in
the right direction
and so that will be the end of this
particular PowerPoint here so if you
want hit the pause button and try to
answer these questions all of these
answers can be found somewhere in this
presentation so if you want write the
answers on a separate piece of paper I'd
be happy to check your answers for
accuracy before class or after class
someday so hit the pause button and good
luck